and
uh so the setting like first uh to
explain
the title briefly is secure multi-party
computation
so we want to allow two or more parties
to a securely available public functions
on their inputs
such that the parties learn the function
output and nothing more
and this is something we know how to do
since a long time ago and
how we even know how to do succinctly
with
uh photomorphic encryption but still a
question is
about concrete deficiencies so this talk
today will be
mostly about yeah concrete efficiency
and one approach towards this is to push
all the expensive um cryptographic parts
to an
input independent pre-processing phase
where the parties generated
generate long correlated strings then
can then be used to implement
a very efficient online phase
and yeah so this has lots of great
properties
the online phase is very lightweight
information theoretic
you can get security against this honest
majority and
against parties behaving maliciously
but the problem with this approach is
still the pre-processing
phase which is expensive because
typically the online
phase requires a large amount
of uh correlated randomness and
in order to produce that typical
protocols require communication and
storage at least
linear in the amount of correlated
randomness needed
and
so um in order like in order to improve
this um
in order to get sublinearity for secure
um
communication what we do is use a like
the simplest thing we can do is use a
pseudorandom generator
and so what we can use here in order to
make is more efficient is a pseudorandom
correlation generator
so pseudo-random correlation generator
allows to extend
short correlated seats into long
correlated pseudo-random strings
and to be a bit more formal if like a
pseudo-random correlation generator it
consists of a
gen algorithm and expand algorithm and
the gen algorithm sets up two seats that
are
um that are yeah correlated and then the
parties can locally
expand those seats k 0 and k 1 to
get to get long long strings and of
course we want correctness so that
these are correlated in whatever way we
um
want them to be correlated and um
and like what is what is a bit more
difficult to get
is um is how to define security
so as i said we want to use that for
secure
computation so maybe the main most
straightforward or
the most desirable notion would be to
get a simulation based
security notion but this turns out um to
be
impossible so we sell for um
or like the definition cells for the
next
um next best thing uh which is a
indistinguishable
based security notion so the crime end
is that
a party um itself from the short seat
cannot learn anything more about the
other party's
um output than it can trip really just
by knowing that the two
are um in a correlate like correlated
and of course now the question is is
this um still useful
and uh like otherwise i wouldn't be
showing it here but it turns out yes you
can even
use it as a direct plug-in for for a
wide number of protocols
um namely all protocols were were
that allow kind of to be replaced the
ideal functionality for pre-processing
by a corruptable
functionality that allows the adversary
to choose its own
randomness and then sample the honest
party's randomness um
conditioned on on the adversarial uh
chosen randomness and a lot of natural
mpc protocols are already secured
in the settings so so for all this um we
can use it as a plug-in replacement
and now just to put these together um
yes sorry lisa this has been a quick
question
um you know the so the security
experiment uh is not uh sort of
polynomial time right
in your previous slide um you know the
security experiment needs to either
sample
uh uh r1 or it needs to sample r1
conditioned on uh
on r0 is that right or am i missing
something
yes so uh the security experiment so
like what we want is it's it's
it's initial whether you just take r1 to
be the expanded
output or you sample r1 conditioned on
being in correlation
with r0 so we need like we consider
correlations where you can do that
ah okay that you can do there where you
can sample this r1 condition on our zero
and polynomial time
yes yes okay okay got it okay thank you
okay thanks for the question there's
just a question in the q a which
is closely related to what the node is
asking which is just what this notation
means so i guess this notation means
like
yes are one conditioned on this
correlation
between r1 yes yes
yes yes and like for correlations that
we want to like
consider like so so generally we'll
consider uh
additive correlations where you can uh
yeah where you can always do this by
just
sampling accordingly okay
okay thank you so um
is there another question
yes so the question is what if there's a
bijection between r zero and i
r one um but neither direction is
efficiently computable
okay so like we care only about
correlations for
where this is efficiently computable
so like like really correlations where
you have like you can efficiently sample
so
like for later you will see for the
applications this the correlations will
be something like
additive secret sharing of of a product
or something like that
where you don't have this problem okay
sorry i should have been more
uh precise about that thanks i hope this
one last clarification once you're ready
so assume that
expand is just a standard prg so the
keys
are chosen uniformly and the output
is pseudorandom by conditional
probability
you mean it is a uniformly random string
or a uniformly random
pseudo-random string in the image of
expand
so like if we
you mean what if we would just
instantiate with a prg
then this like this this wouldn't say
anything or this would just say okay
like if i just instantiate it with a prg
then i know the other party's output
because
um i know that the other party's output
is my output because the correlation
would be the equality corr
like equality
correlation so so r1 doesn't have to be
in the
image of expand correct
oh so um yeah yeah yeah no like like
from any it's it's it's
indistinguishable from any r1 not just
from an r1 that is in the image from
from expand so it's like really it's
like it's it's it's random so you have
some sort of
like pseudorandomness there so it's
indistinguishable like computationally
indistinguishable
from from any other value that would be
that would be correlated to r0 but it
does not have to be in expand for any
key
key k1 so so this relation is given to
you separate it's not a relation that
so there is a relation between r0 and r1
which is defined
implicitly by the two expand
functions and the execution of gen
1 so the correlation we have a
correlation like
um i i should have explained this
differently the correlation is given
ahead of time
and then you you you find a pcg for that
correlation
so the correlation is fixed and then you
find a pcg for that correlation
and for the correlation you want the
security requirement to hold
so like you can replace this correlation
by something
get like that you can get by the by the
pcg because
because the output of the pcg is
indistinguishable
from something that is just sampled
according to this correlation even from
my
you does this make sense thanks yeah
yeah okay perfect okay okay great thanks
uh
okay thanks for your questions i hope
the definition is clear now it's
actually very important
so uh so thank you um
and now that we have it so yeah we will
always consider like a fixed correlation
and later i will be more explicit about
this
but like once we have a pcg for this
correlation we care about
we can now use this to get more
efficient style and pre-processing
because we can um we can now have a set
up with
uh with some linear communication and
storage like storage for sure because
the parties just have to store the short
seat
um and and of um like we can also hope
to get away with much less communication
and then the pre-processing itself will
be will be completely silent so
um once they see the setup there's no
more communication between the
parties uh required so what you get is a
secure npc with silent pre-processing in
particular
sub-linear communication and storage and
this
this is very nice also for um also for
malicious security because now for
to make it maliciously secure you only
have to make the setup phase
secure so even if you have like a small
overhead the expansion and the
computational time is almost not
affected by that so you get malicious
securities it's also something we show
in this line of work at very little
extra cost and um now this is
uh maybe like maybe something um to do
also to make the correlations a bit more
clear if we have like a fixed
correlation
and hereby correlation is an additive
correlation so i want
um i want to have r0 and r1 um
such that r0 plus r1 are equal to f
of x for some x that is chosen uniformly
in random and f
is the correlation we care about and now
here you can also see if like that verse
3 provides r1
we can just sample r0 as f
f of x minus r minus r1
and have something that satisfies um the
correlation and
we will always like i will just talk
about additive correlations
and um and for feasibility this is also
i mean
like a lot of this talks in this week
were about um uh were actually about
just
feasibility and here like we will have
feasibility after the slide and then the
rest of the talk will be about
um concrete efficiency so you can get
pcg for this correlation
by if you have a prg and the suitable
homomorphic secret sharing scheme
and homomorphic secret sharing scheme is
um already something
we saw in ayu's talk on tuesday
it's basically just as a reminder it's
the
secret sharing analog of fully
homomorphic encryptions so that allows
you have secret shares and you can do
homomorphic computations on the shares
and um here the difference here is that
we really
want need to homomorphic signage sharing
where the reconstruction is additive
so how we how we can how we can we use
this if we have that
now we can instead of sampling x we can
sample a short c of x and share this
with the homomorphic secret sharing
scheme between the two parties
and then using the homomorphic secret
sharing scheme we can evaluate first the
prg
and then the function f that we care
about the correlation we care about on
the shares
and then by correctness of the
homomorphic secret sharing scheme we
will have that r0 plus r1
equals f of prd of x uh
f of pure d of the seat of x so f of x
and because
the the the seed will be much shorter
than x and homomorphic secret sharing we
have succinctness of the shares this
will also
like actually give us something
interesting so something that is
compressing
and uh yeah so this gives us already a
feasibility
and and and this is kind of also what
what makes this landscape at least like
the orange and the yellow part
so building on homomorphic secret
sharing techniques you can basically
get something for general additive um
correlations and you can also like on
the other side
is this you can get from one-way
functions you can get interesting things
you can get
um truth-table correlations
you can get linear linear correlations
for multiple like in a multi-party case
this is something
um already from like 20 years ago kind
of the start of pcgs
and uh yeah and and as you can see
there's a
there's a white missing and i think
there was a question should i
uh the question is just what lwe plus
means oh like
uh like lwe just with the with uh with
circular
security like the circular security
requirement that you don't have to know
a priori like the depth of the circuit
and
uh yes and there's like a big blank here
and this plank here is
i have to click again and so this is
actually what i want to talk about but
um
today is that it turns out that lapland
so the
learning party with noise assumption
turns out to be very useful to
um construct completely efficient pcg so
as you can see here this is like a lot
of
green uh green um
things uh vector oblivious linear
evaluation oblivious trench for
oblivious
linear evaluation something we showed
like in a very recent work from a
variant of ring learning parody with
noise
and uh yes so ot and all e this is the
two things i also want
uh to talk about today and
yes i think i'll continue with this and
about some things i'll i'll talk more
later
and as we have alisa this is
just a quick question your previous
previous slide when you wrote f of
capital x
is capital x some sort of input or
so i think of it as a random variable
from some distribution
i think of it as an input for that so
like you sample it like you can i mean
you can you sample it
uniformly so if you set up the
correlation you will sample this
so it's it's uh it's a random variable
but
but here you can think of like i want to
instantiate it so i sample a random x
and then and then i i plug it in into f
or like
and then in the pcg i sample instead of
c of x and then use the prg to get the x
okay so it shouldn't be related to like
inputs to
mpc or that kind of inputs
uh so this is so this is all random so
this will all randomness because
like in the pre-processing phase what
you want to generate is just
like completely like you just need
pseudorandom correlations in the end so
so so this will later this will not have
nothing to do with the actual inputs for
the mpc this is just really
something that you want to be random
okay thank you
okay thanks for the question
uh okay great and uh so
uh so yes we have seen this uh this week
i've seen a lot of uh
like more learning with errors or like i
yes i think no learning parody with
noise and
so what's what's the difference between
the two so first of all learning parody
with noise as
as as the name says it was originally or
like
does consider um correlations or that
does consider is is over f2
but actually here we will consider also
arithmetic versions of that so like you
don't
like you can think of p being two being
larger um we will have
we will see both in this talk and so the
difference that that makes
that makes lpn for the setting
interesting and and and the difference
that we have is really
how the area is distributed and in lwe
it we have
error with small infinity norm and for
learning particularly with noise we
have uh errors with small hamming weight
so the
like um the basically you can view the
error as a sparse vector and this is
where like the magic comes from and uh
yes
so we have seen that from learning with
errors like
uh or like we you can do a lot of like
you can do a lot a lot of things and a
lot of great things like
homework encryption not uh as we've seen
like the last days not not all yet that
we want to do so
i are still still outside but like
already a lot of things and and how
how does this work look for learning
parody with mice so actually what we get
is much smaller so if we just
considered learning pretty nice we can
do basic things like prg
secret key encryption one-way functions
um but
um but but like really not a lot and if
we
if we go too low now noise so um we have
as far as
errors with just few entries like a less
than a square root of n
then we can do more we can do public key
encryption or t but it's still
like a lot less expressive than than
than lwe but what we will get here is
actually like concrete efficiency and
this is like a
like a setting where really lpn gets
something much more efficient than lwe
as you will see
and what i will show in this talk is how
you can get pcg for ot
actually for learning parity with
learning parity with noise with
arbitrary
noise rate and uh
pcpgs for oblivious linear evaluation if
you go to the low
noise rate regime and this is something
i want to this is the two things i want
to talk about today
and yes
um so why is why is uh
why are um why is learning party with
noise
so um so great or like like first okay
um
basically as you've seen before like
what we want for for making pcgs work
is absolute random generator and and how
do we get the random generator from
learning party with mice
well like one way is just to you can
just view the
the seed is just the secret and the
arrow positions of the sparse vector
that can then
extend and this is already something and
this also gives you something but this
is limited to quadratic stretch because
if you go
um beyond quadratic stretch you can just
guess enough noise-free
coordinates and and then trivially
solved by gaussian elimination
um so if we want to go further what we
will do is go to the dual
lpn assumption where like if you
consider the matrix that's a parity
check matrix if you view it as like a
code
um to to generate your matrix
g then those two assumptions are
equivalent
and um and now we can have arbitrary
polynomial stretch and the reason is
just because now we don't have to
also give the secret as a seat so the
secret can be larger now and but that
doesn't
like now we don't have limited stretch
so this is
um this is what we will use um and the
two assumption can be shown to be
equivalent
and um
why why why does this why is this a
perfect match
for pseudorandom correlation generators
so there's like two reason and the
important reason is
that that's also what's the difference
to learning uh with errors
is that the sparse vector can be
distributed via compressed secret shares
so
i can in the next slide i will explain
what it means in more detail but you can
find like a compressed way
um to to to distribute seats that you
can then extend to get an
additive secret sharing of a sparse
vector and the second thing
is that and this is basically what will
give us the compression and the second
thing is
is if you see this is just a matrix
multiplication so this is
completely like the prg evaluation
except for like
transforming error positions in
something something longer
is completely linear so this has like
nice homomorphic properties so basically
we can just do linear operations
on additive secret shares so like the
simplest homomorphic secret sharing
scheme
you can think of in some sense and
um yeah why why can you why can you
distribute sparse vectors efficiently so
so for this
we've all actually not like we i will
like explain how to
um how to distribute the unit vector
efficiently and if you
distribute the unit vector efficiently
then you can distribute the sparse
vector efficiently
by just like distributing many unit
vectors and add up
the the outcome and we will not view it
as a unit vector but we will
view it as a point function so point
function is something
that um came up uh yesterday in venkatas
talk uh briefly and um what a
point function does is just a function
that's that's that's
non-zero just at one point and and it's
like we view it in a different setting
here so
the the output space will correspond to
the two to the length of the vector
so if you have like a vector of length n
you can view this like a unit vector of
length n you can view this as the output
like the complete output of a point
function that is just
non-zero at at this one point and
like now distributed point function is
just a compressed version to like give
out k0 and k1 to two parties that they
can
extend to and like here extending
meaning evaluating at point one two
three alpha and n
and then if you add it up you get zero
everywhere except for this point y
and and like the the properties of
distributed point functions
is that the parties don't learn what
alpha is and the
parties also don't learn what y is so
like other than the picture where the
first party could see where alpha is
this is this is not the case
and this is nice because uh like why why
so we have efficient constructions of
those distributed point functions
as a compressing constructions of sparse
vectors from one-way functions and
what you also need for pcgs you don't
even you don't only care about
um about that you have a pcg you also
need to set up the seat efficiently
and for for those constructions by
durner and chill out there and that
actually um exists
efficient distributed setup of the seats
and i think there was a question
yeah so there's just a quick question
from mark which is what the quantifier
on y
is what what is
sorry how why is quant how is y
quantified like
so why like later you will see what y is
like y
will later be chosen by one of the
parties basically
but so you will see how this y
is chosen later i i i think like later
it's easier to to explain what it's good
for
and uh so it's just a fixed y so you can
view the point function as index by
alpha and y
so it's a bit sloppy i didn't write it
this way maybe this answers the question
also
and now that you've seen this actually
and and now we have a distributed point
function so we can compress a unit
vector
between two parties and and as we can
compress the unit vector as i said
we can compress um like any sparse
vector
and um and this is actually like those
two slides are actually all you need
to know like all you need you kind of
already uh
now should know how to do like a pcg
from learning
parity with noise this is like really
the main ingredients but now i want to
take the rest of the talk
um to to give a bit more details how
good we do we get a pcg
for oblivious transfer from learning
priority with noise just
basically with these techniques we can
do with something smarter and get better
um efficiency but this is already enough
and and later in the end like i want to
spend a few minutes to talk how can we
get all these from like uh
kind of a bit different assumption but
efficiently
and um so oblivious transfer
uh like just very briefly allows
uh bob to obliviously send a message to
alice so does
that like alice just learns one of the
messages and bob doesn't learn
which um message alice chose to learn
and
this actually like by kilian we know
that this implies
a secure multi-party computation and not
only this with
for example gmw protocol we can get very
very efficient um secure computation if
we have lots of
um like lots of random ot's
so um basically in the pre-processing
they set up many
of these and this is great then the only
problem that we have is that
ot is expensive it's a public key
primitive which are generally expensive
and to overcome this um what
like originally beaver and um later
ishai
and all uh worked on was so-called ot
extension and the idea
of ot extension is okay like there is a
result that i cannot get
um out without um ot completely but what
i can do is
i i can just need blackboard access to
like a few
um ots and then the rest i can i can do
with cheap symmetric crypto and and so i
get something like this basically solves
the computational
efficiency kind of um point but but the
problem is like we still have a lot of
communication so
this is of course um necessary if i care
about chosen ot's but in the context of
um secure computation i just care about
random ot's so
um in order to do random ot's i can
actually use the pseudorandom
correlation generates as i saw before to
get
what we call silent or t extension where
like additional to
the computational savings you have
saving in terms of storage and
communication
and so yes i want to spend
a few words on like what ot extension
protocols are known so like as i said
the first one was by beaver like took
around but not practically efficient and
then later
there was a number of protocols which
got which are concretely efficient but
with the downside that they require
actually like first like like or
with the downside like okay i'm um with
the downside that they require still a
lot of communication so
um communication is still like
even in the order of 70 bits even if you
only care
about um about the single bit of t so
for single bit of t
you still needed to communicate like a
lot of bits and this is something
if you use pcgs you can actually bring
down so asymptotically to zero bits but
with concrete implementation even
concretely you get something like
0.1 bit so almost a factor of thousand
improvement
and another interesting so this is just
kind of the advertisement slide why you
should continue listening for the rest
of the talk
um another interesting um result of this
line of work is that it gives you the
first efficient two-round ot extension
and so
in in some sense there was a low bound
by target all that
from symmetric um key primitives
you cannot get in a black box white two
round ot extension of course our
construction is not
uh it's not black box but um it has
like as i said in some sense it lives in
the symmetric
it can live in symmetric keywords so um
yes it's also something
like i find interesting and it has a lot
of practical applications so directly
a big improvement to semi-honest
two-party computation
uh improved improvements on private set
intersection malicious mpc and also
applications
to non-interactive secure um computation
and uh yeah so the rest i want to
explain how this is
done now um that i said well like what
you can
what's the result is um and so like i
i showed you the um oblivious transfer
correlation it's not it's not it's like
the way i wrote it it's not very linear
so the first step
is to um rewrite it as something that
looks more linear
and and then it does like therefore is
more friendly for
um the learning parity with noise
assumption as i said before
and how we can do this instead of
starting with ot we start with
correlated ot
and correlated ot is exactly the same it
looks very different on the slide but
it's exactly the same
except that the sender chooses always
like
only one message and the second message
is a constant offset of this message
and um and then you can rewrite what
alice gets it's r it's not
rbi as before but it's ri plus
either delta if bi is one or just ri
if if if it's zero and um it was shown
that if you have correlated ot and a
correlation robust hash function then
you can get um
oblivious transfer so it's actually all
we need to show
is how we can get this correlated ot and
now this correlated ot this looks
already like if you look at
the dark blue and the light blue vectors
like or if you look then this adds up to
delta times bi
because the ri we're over f2 so the ra
cancels out
so if you if you write it now it's like
you want many of this so write it as
vectors then this
this adds up that the parties like the
the light blue and the dark blue
add up to a secret sharing of delta
times the vector b
and um so in other words this
is actually if uh subfield vector
oblivious linear revelation if you're
familiar with it if not
it's not necessary for the rest of the
talk and it's subfield
uh because bi here is is a choice bit
source
either zero or one and uh yes
so now that we have that um we can use
what i told you before
because um delta times b and
so what you need is a is an efficient is
a compression of delta times
b such that that adds up to the secret
sharing this is exactly what we need
and so what we can use is we can use the
distributed point function
as i said before to get a
efficient compression k 0 and k 1 of the
vector that is the delta here so to
answer the question
before the y before is the delta here
this is something that is chosen and
only known to the sender
and um so if if we have that
then we can repeat uh this many times
via addition
and uh and then so this is just like
you just get many keys and then you
evaluate all the keys and then you add
it all up
and then with learning parity with noise
you can you get from something that is
just a sparse vector you get to
suit a random vector and here you you
you you basically use the linearity so
that
delta delta times the matrix times the
vector is the same as
the matrix times delta times the vector
so this would and
it gets a bit smaller because we have
this kind of trinkets if you remember
the slide on on the dual lpn um
assumption so this is all like this is
actually all like what i said before
this is uh this is all the magic where
the magic
uh comes from and uh but now i want to
go a bit into detail about the steps and
and how how we actually do it
so um first
i promised a two-round uh two-round
distributed setup i said we can get
two-round rt extension
and actually as i wrote it you cannot
get uh to run ot extension because
distributed point functions you can
set them up very efficiently in a
distributed way but you need
a log n numbers of communication where n
is the
is the length of the output so this is
certainly not two
but an observation that
that you can make here is that in in the
setting we the
distributed point functions are actually
kind of an overcoat
why is that because actually the
receiver knows um
knows the vector b so uh the vector b
the red like it's the choice bit so that
in particular
the receiver knows the the point where
the point function is not equal to zero
so that so so the receiver
knows exactly the non-zero positions and
then we can
use a different uh primitive we can use
actually so-called punctuable
pseudorandom function and
punctual pseudonym functions are special
case of
constrained pseudorandom functions that
we've seen this week
for example in written talk on monday
and
punch triple yes practical website
random fractions allow
to puncture a key so if you have the
punctured key
you can learn the pseudo-random function
on all points except for this point
where it's punctured and
um you can get like
there's results that you can get the
constructions like just based on on
on the on the gtm prf construction
um so if you just
as a short reminder and there like you
can see the tree and you go along the
tree by taking either
the left hand or the right hand output
of a pseudo random generator that's
length doubling
and if if if i just give out of course
if i give out the green key
you can learn everything but if i give
out instead the orange keys then
what you can learn is is exactly what is
orange and blue so you can learn
everything except for alpha
and and the key size is is lambda times
the length of the trees so log n so in
particular again
like maybe as a reminder because usually
we want a puncture
like we want two random functions to
have exponential output here like we
have
the output is n it's the output that we
want to compute so this is something
polynomial
and like that so we will actually always
evaluate the complete
pseudorandom function and
okay so
yeah i don't know is there questions or
there's things blinking
well zvika was just wondering uh what
noise you can handle for the
lpn
um so like how
high or how low the noise has to be
okay so like for a practical
instantiation
like we of course want very very low
noise because like the noise is because
you have to
repeat it noise many times so this is
this is directly how much communication
you will have
but you can go like anything that still
gives you something
uh non like that gives you something
non-trivial in terms of uh stretch so
you can even like slightly
uh
yeah i have to like like like anything
like you can go as
as like you can go as far up as the
noise
that you want but you of course like you
want to stop somewhere to get something
non-trivial but
like the the the construction itself is
not it's not it's not depending on
like how much noise you have certainly
you can have larger noise
a larger noise than square root of n and
you still get something interesting
i hope this answers the question
is there another question
okay so um now that you have um punctual
absolute random functions you can just
you have already a pcg for unit vector
by just giving
you just give bob the key and you give
alice the punctured key
and also delta blinded by the value at
the punctured function and this hides
delta because
um because yeah because of the security
of the
punctual pseudorandom function and just
by adding up it will all add up to zero
at except for this one point where it
will add up to your value alpha so you
have correctness this
uh where it will add up to delta so you
get exactly what you want
and now still the question is of course
how can we set up
mk star and k and um
and this like in particular how can we
get a two-round setup and the strategy
is based on
the the the protocol for distributed
point functions of direction
but optimized through the setting um of
uh
of punctual pseudorandom functions and
the idea is
now the sender can choose so the so the
problem is like maybe
like you can say why is it problem why
can't i just the sender choose k and
then
the sender sent k star to to others but
of course the sender cannot learn
alpha because if the sender would learn
alpha then
um then he would learn kind of the noise
and then we would have like we would
have security from the
from then then he could learn the noise
and then he could learn uh
the input choice of alice so
um so we have to find a way so that uh
bob can obliviously give k star to alice
and this can be done
via ots because actually what what alice
needs is exactly the values that are off
the path alpha
so she can give this as an input like
choice inputs to an
oblivious transfer protocol and bob can
just
um like in the first level it's easy he
just gives the right and the left leaves
and in the in the next level this is
this is from donor schillat he can give
like the sum of the right leaves and
some of the left leaves and this is
actually sufficient for alice to compute
what she needs and
what is special about this is that these
ortiz can be excluded in parallel
because
alice knows the path from the beginning
and bob knows the key from the beginning
so there's nothing adaptive
what you need for distributed point
function and
yes and then like we said like we need
to get from unit to sparse vectors
uh this yeah well you just add up um
and you can even do something smarter so
you can instead of adding up you can
choose
smaller vectors and use concatenation
and then you need to assume uh learning
parity with noise with reg
learning parity with regular noise
instead so where you know like you have
the noise and you know here is exactly
one noise coordinate here is one noise
coordinate here's one noise coordinate
but like this also for um
this seems not like to be broken
by by by similar attack so so you can um
you can you can also use this for more
efficiency
and then the third part is the the
bringing in the learning parity with
nice so how can we get from sparse to
pseudorandom vectors is just by
multiplying
um this this vector the the parity check
matrix
and here is the main challenge and this
is something that i haven't like really
said before
so the problem of our approach is that
this pretty check matrix is
big so it will be as large as that
output size so if you care about
generating 10 million ots the dimension
will be 10 million
and so what you can do is for example
use quasi cyclic codes
to get multiplication and log n so
this makes it makes it more practical
it's still
slower door so from a computational
viewpoint it's still slower than
than for example ikmp but i'll say more
about this in a slide
and what you get for security is
the security is similar like if you use
quasi-cyclic code it's similar to
quantum cryptosystem like bike and hqc
but like just
to to stress here again using this kind
of assumption is only for concrete
efficiency if you just care about
like getting if you just care about
feasibility or constructing something
you can
use very conservative assumption you can
just use
a random matrix and you can use very
high noise so it's really like it's
really a trade-off between security and
efficiency and um
yeah to to um put it all together
this um how how does it look like how
does um pseudorandom correlation
generators
for correlated ot look like well alice
sets up alpha i bob sets up the keys so
i
times like each one for one of the noise
vectors so the more noise vectors we
have the more communication
and computation is required and also
chooses the delta
um sends ki star as
as described to alice and then they can
they can expand it so
um and then finally locally multiply the
matrix and just because
of the linearity of the lpn assumption
the output will actually be give
give a correlated or give correlated
pseudorandom of t
and now going from correlated ot
to chosen ot so first one has to break
the correlations
so you have to locally apply um
correlation robust hash function
actually we need something
slightly um we need something
slightly stronger we need a a
correlated input secure hash function
um because you get some extra
information about short explanations of
the inputs
but this is so both are like
you can like if you go to practice you
can use is or something to instantiate
this
and this gives you mpc with two-round
silent pre-processing
and then as i promised uh a promise
also to round ot extension if you talk
about ot extension like i talked only
about random ot's but
of course um like like in
generally you will also care about
chosen ortiz for like you you like the
receiver
like the send receiver really chooses
which messages
she wants to get and the sender really
chooses which messages he wants to send
and um now the question is can we deal
randomized also in in two messages
and the answer is yes because the
the the receiver the sender can in any
case send his serialization with the
second message
and the de-randomization of the of of
alice just depends on b
and b can be computed by her without any
any knowledge of anything of of
of of bob so it's it actually gives a
two-round ot extension and it even
even can give with malicious security in
the fiat chamier
um you can get a two-round maliciously
security extension
if you don't want to go use fiat amir
you get a four-round maliciously
security extension
and actually like you have to so you
have to
it's a slightly different assumption you
have to allow some leakage on on
on the lpn but but this is also
something that like
intuitively doesn't make doesn't doesn't
give any attacks by just
increasing the noise rate a bit and so
just as a comparison uh what you will
get
is in to to generate 10 million random
ot's as i said
the problem or the bottleneck of our
purchase is the computation
so if you have a very fast connection
and
like small like not small and slow
computer
then you will have like you want to use
you still want to use iknp but
the more so um as you can see here i can
p goes from 0.2 seconds
to uh to something over two minutes um
so it's very sensitive to the network
connection speed and and this is
something that um
uh like using pcgs with the silent
silence
with the silent feature you don't have
as you can see the
it's it almost doesn't change it go from
3.3 to 3.6 seconds so you get really
almost factor 50 improvements if
communication is the bottleneck and
yes so this was um to this was what i
want to say
for like ot and ot extension and maybe
are there any questions and if not i
would continue to the second empire
[Music]
maybe you can read it i don't understand
the question
yes so the question is when you improve
the dpf side of the approachable pgs
you still have to do this logarithmic
number of times
why is it better than the four before so
what is like what
is so it's not about so we need to do it
like
however the noise rate is t many times
but this
like it can be like this is uh can can
be small
but the number frown so it's really the
number of rounds you need so and
and for dpfs it's like how you
how you set up the keys so it's just
about setting up k
and k star or the dpf keys k 0 and k1
you need
to to this is an adaptive procedure so
to do it
like once you need really log n rounds
and now you only need
two rounds with punchable prgs and and
of course you have to repeat t
times but you can do it all in two
rounds you just do all the rounds in in
in two times those completely
independent things so
so is is this like this is just about
bringing down the number of rounds
i hope this answers the question
um any other questions
no okay then i'll continue with the
second part
um so how can we get oblivious linear
revelation from learning
parity with noise first and then how can
we get something more efficient
and so oblivious linear revelation is
just a
generalization of oblivious transfer to
larger fields fp so instead of
l is choosing 001 so it getting like one
or the other message of
bob she will get a linear evaluation of
um the function by bob so a
b plus c and um
this is maybe like maybe something
that's more used
um if you have all these you can locally
transform it into a multiplication
triple
so into a triple such that um alice and
bob
share um uh have an additive secret
sharing of
a product a times b and and also both
have secret
sharings of a and secret chains of b so
a 0 b 0
and a b 0 and and the same for bob
and uh yeah this this can be used for um
for
secure computation over over large
fields
and again like you already see the
colors so you already see maybe what's
coming like we want to rewrite it to get
like to be able to use the techniques um
and how you can rewrite it you can write
it as a
a times b so um this is just the com
entry vice product of a times b and is
secret shared between the parties
so is d minus c and and this is just by
this is just rewinding the above
so now that we know this um like we can
just
basically do the same as before uh we
just have to
find a good way to write it so you can
write it like you can write it
um as a times b transposed and then just
ignore everything that's not in the
diagonal like what we really care about
is on the diagonal
but now m a times b transposed um you
can
again just use lpn to compress a and b
so you can replace a by something sparse
like h times something sparse and b by h
times something sparse and then
like just plugging it in and the
equation you have this is this is what
it looks like
and now you can change the brackets and
what you get is
h times um sparse matrix
times h transpose and
this is great because now we just have
like the only thing we have to compress
is the sparse matrix and we know how to
like we can just use
bias matrix again as a point function
and we know how to compress it of course
we lose
lose a bit so now we have so there's
like two
observations so we lose a bit we have
now t squared
coefficient so this means now we really
can only have noise uh square root
like square root of n because if like
below square root of n if we would have
more than square root of n
then this would get like trivial now it
would not be a sparse vector anymore
um but um but still if we go to smaller
noise this this still gives
something gives something interesting
and i think there was a question
or what is it the same question
i know like maybe we can take it to the
end yeah
um if there's any question right now you
do have ten minutes
okay thanks i should be good um
[Music]
so yes and the second problem so this is
one problem but this seems somewhat
inherent but the second problem is
also the dimension grows so quadratic
and now the computational cross
cost crossword diatic so now we're at n
squared log n squared
and and and so this is this is too much
to be to be practical from
from efficiency viewpoint another
question
no maybe not um i'm just gonna
wait until the end um it's yeah it's not
far
um and uh so what can we do so what
what we can do is like we can write it
in a different way so instead of
writing it as as like
as a matrix with the matrix left and
right we can also write it as a tensor
product
and then like the matrix which just
consists of all the all the antivirus
um row products of this matrix so this
is like
quadratically big and now like you can
like maybe
like now you can ask like why would you
do this because actually this made
things worse because now we don't have
structure
so now the the straightforward
computation time would be n to the four
um or like whatever you need to to
multiply n squared matrices yeah and to
the four
and now but the observation like the
first observation is why it's
interesting this generalizes two more
dimensions so you can do
like you can get this for arbitrary
constant decrease so this is like
theoretically this is interesting
and now you can also optimize that so
you can get the better efficiency by
choosing h such that this long matrix h
is compressible and compressible in
which sense so compressible in the sense
that only few of this roast are just its
row products are distinct
so that you kind of like a lot of them
are the same and so you can just
compress the matrix down and compress
the the tensor product down and then
have like have something that's more
efficient
and like one way to do it is we are
using ring
learning party with noise and so now
this first looks very different but the
idea is
um instead of like like
for for ring learning with errors
instead of using matrix
times vector you have uh you have
polynomial multiplication so you have a
public matrix a
public polynomial a and you have sparse
so sparse and like meaning sparse
coefficients
s of x and e of x and an assumption is
that this looks
close to u of x over set px mod
5x for some polynomial phi and
yes so this looks more like uh now more
like the
so maybe like first intuition why does
this give something better because now
basically
instead of tensor product you have a
polynomial multiplication
so instead of going from n to n squared
you go from n to
2n so this is much better and you can
actually also put it in the picture that
i have before
because if if i fully splits over set p
then you can write it as like going from
the
coefficient representation to the um
evaluation representation you can use
the van der waals matrix just consisting
of all the
um corresponding to all the evaluations
of series of
um of phi and and a is just like writing
it like this a just corresponds to the
matrix representation of a uh of of the
polynomial a so this of course depends
on
on how phi looks like and actually like
why does this give such a nice matrix as
we had before it turns out that if
uh phi fully splits then you you can
rewrite a
v as v times just a diagonal matrix
so this is basically just a scaled
fundament matrix and one amount matrix
is have this nice property that
that i mean it just corresponds to like
it's just
the same why you have this for
polynomials and and then you only have
like a linear growth so you only go from
n
to three n so you need s x times s x
squared
s x times e x and like and across terms
and uh yes so this actually gives us
just one to show us in the matrix makes
this representation and this gives
a now and all is over set p in o tilde
of n computation time of course now you
have to assume
a ring lpn like an arithmetic version of
ring lp and so
so obviously this only works over big
fields that v
that fee fully splits and you have to
assume that even if it splits like you
have security so there's some attacks
that that you can tear it take care of
and
and we did we did the analysis and uh we
believe it's secure but this is
certainly something that
we hope more people will will look into
and
um regarding efficiency um so
like recently like uh to get all
east you could use for example over
triumph of caloridal
but there you have freely like the
problem is really the communication so
you have more than a gigabyte of
communication even for just one million
all east which is
about 32 megabytes and you could get
something this was like i don't know if
anyone saw the small green star you can
get something interesting even from
learning with errors
and together with the mq assumption for
for for very like low degree
pseudo-random generator
but this only gives you something this
actually gives you some
reasonable efficiency but only if you
start with a very large seat
because basically yeah just because lwe
cyber techs are very big so you have to
start with
three gigabyte seeds to even get any um
any expansion uh but then
like you get like much less
communication six gigabyte but it gives
you
three three gigabyte and not just 32
megabytes but with this new approach you
actually get even for
just one million ots you get down to
seven like approximately this is very
estimated but just to give you like a
like an order of magnitude you get like
even less communication that the
amount of of triples you want
and as a reasonable efficiency and the
efficiency again should be taken with
some care because
um you need extra if like you need extra
time for for for for setting up the seat
so this this is just
the expansion times of just the silent
pre-processing time
but like for exa in particular for the
last one there
you you can do you can actually reuse
all these so you need a lot of old east
so you have a
like expensive set of cost once and then
like from then you can reuse the ole e's
if you want to
if you want to redo the setup so this is
a nice property
and further we also get malicious
security making basically making
the the distributed point functions
um set up from donor enchilad making it
maliciously secure
and it generalizes to authenticated
multiplication triples at very
low cost this is like a nice property
also about
the linearity of learning parity with
noise that going from triples to
authenticated triples
is almost for free so it's not even
though it's like a degree three rim
correlation it does not cost you like
how like a degree correlation would
would cost you and
uh yes so this was just like a short um
excursion to to to to to give some ideas
of the
of of this work and uh to conclude this
talk
um uh yeah i talked about pcgs for
oblivious transfer
from learning parity with noise i mean i
mostly talked about by learning partly
with noise and and
is nice for for pseudo-ram correlation
generators
so you get for random ot gets something
practical almost zero communication
and we have a two round of extension
which malicious security also have an
implementation and
for uh we showed like very recently that
for oblivious linear elevation you can
get a more efficient instantiation based
on fully splittable
um ring at lpn
and there's a lot of work still to do in
this area as it's a very like young
area so one thing i kind of already
mentioned
is um is to optimize oblivious transfers
to find better codes like quasi-linear
is something i mean
the difficulty is is of course to find
something that is like it's efficient
to evaluate like it's efficient to
evaluate to take age
times this error that should be
efficient but learning parity with noise
um should be um has to be hard like
otherwise um
of course that we don't have security um
in like generally can we extend the
techniques now we extend it to all east
to get something efficient can we get
um and multiplication triples can we get
it for more correlations
and like a better understanding so we
use a
lot a lot of like kind of new flavors of
lpn assumptions like can we get a better
understanding of
um of the security can we relate it to
other
known things uh yeah other attacks so
this is
uh yeah lots of things to do and with
this
i want to conclude my talk uh thanks
yeah very much for attention again
for the invitation um to the workshop
okay so and i think there's a bit of
time for question i don't know yeah
there's a little bit of time for
questions so maybe we can take we can
take a few if
if people have
uh so can you can you see the q a maybe
maybe you can
uh yes so maybe for some applications
correlations you can do the same from
lwe so this is
actually like a very interesting
question so as i said like
like um what we have from lwe is like
using lwe
to construct a homomorphic secret
sharing scheme and
then use like a very low degree like a
degree two
pseudonym correlation generator of
course a different um
a different direction would be using lwe
the way
we use um learning quality with nice but
we don't know of any efficient way to
compress
and to compress this noise so it's not
it's not clear it seems really
um that lpn seems to give
something more efficient for like
yeah for for all things we know but
certainly like to extend the techniques
and to look in what can be done for lw
is an interesting problem
uh other questions
uh in the pcg for okay so that the next
question
is in the pcg for ot from learning
parody with noise
how does one of the parties get the
value prf
k of alpha plus delta into rounds so
this is something that
um for ot it's actually very
like quite simple because the sender
can't just send it because the sender
knows he can evaluate the
random oh no okay now this is of course
wrong because he doesn't know where
alpha is
so you do the same trick as you do
before and you sum up
all the leaves so you sum up like you
just sum up all the leaves
of the of the of the gtm tree you sum up
all the leaves and then you
add delta and because the other party
can
compute all the leaves except for the
one leaf and the other party can get
all the leaves can exactly get this
value plus delta
and but this is something that the the
sender can just send along so this is
just with a second or t message just
send this
along okay great
um so let's take any remaining questions
uh offline um and let's
do uh let's reconvene in in nine minutes
let's say for for niko's talk so uh
pacific time that would be
uh 9 45. okay and let's uh thank lisa
again